when it comes to overseas travel in a
global pandemic
the unpredictability is enough to put
anyone off
but now some clarity about who can go
where and what the consequences will be
but it's all too late for tour operators
like fiona charrington
this summer is pretty much a write-off
we need to know that the decisions taken
now
stay in place to give people the
confidence to book and to know that
they're not worrying from the moment
they do book
that the holiday is going to be taken
away from them at the last minute or
while they're away
in the latest government update france
is back on the straight forward amber
list
with travellers no longer needing to
quarantine on return
sarah andrews is delighted she's off to
the pyrenees for a cycling holiday next
week
and was ready to cancel if she'd had to
self-isolate when she got back
brilliant that's just exactly the news
we wanted to hear
because it just means we can go we
cannot worry about
um what we have to do when we get back
that we're both doubly vaccinated so we
can
we can come home and and then get back
to straight back to work
relief too for passengers bound for
greece and spain
after speculation holidaymakers would
need to quarantine on return
but passengers heading to spain are
given the rather
vague advice to get a pcr lab test where
possible
before heading home instead of a more
simple lateral flow test
in 2019 before kovic changed everything
18 million people from the uk headed to
spain
and 10 million to france hardly
surprising that every announcement
is so eagerly awaited other changes
coming in from
sunday include austria germany and
norway among others
going on the government's green list
while india bahrain qatar and the uae
will be moved from red to amber and
destinations including mexico and la
reunion
being added to the red list the prime
minister says he understands what's at
stake
i know how important holidays are to
people people think about them they save
up for them
people yearn to go abroad this year
totally i totally get that we've got to
balance that
against the need to protect our country
against the influx of
of new variants with costly testing
form filling and constant speculation
about lists
braving any overseas trip takes some
determination
but at least travellers finally have a
clearer idea
whether or not their summer holiday can
go ahead
emma virtually sky news